I WOULD CALL THE MEETING TO
ORDER WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE --
GOING TO GIVE DICK GAVEL.
TO SUBCOMMITTEE ON A TO OUR VICE
CHAIR.
WHO'S NOT LISTENING TO ME --
SO LIKE HIM PRESENT ON AB
[inaudible]
TEN SIXTY FIVE YEAH.
DID DID SHORTENED VERSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ITEM
PRESENTING --
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE HAS BEEN HERE
BEFORE --
WE'VE MADE SOME SOME JUST
ASSEMBLY BILL.
MUCH BETTER THAN IT WAS BEFORE
SHE I'VE WITH ME TODAY
[inaudible]
WE HAVE [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
SO IT.
AS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND FELIZ
ON HALF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE --
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID THIS
BILL HAS BEEN HURTING THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE --
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROP --
FORTY SEVEN THERE WAS AN
INCREASE IN A ORGANIZE RETAIL
THEFT IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER ARE.
PENAL CODE --
NEEDS TO BE UPDATED TO INCLUDE A
SPECIFIC --
CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
RIGHT NOW ALL WE HAVE IS OUR
JOBS NEW SHOPLIFTING IS TO BE.
THE THE PAYOFF AFTER PETTY THEFT
THE PRIOR --
THIS BILL REMEDIES THAT A
PROBLEM --
AND SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
WE GET TO MY MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STACEY DOILY ON BEHALF
OF THE RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION.
AS WELL AS TARGET AND HOME DEPOT
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR AND ON
THE PROPONENTS OF THE MEASURE
AND ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
WITH US ON A VERY SPECIFIC
RETAIL.
ISSUE THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
US HOME.
AND THE DEFINITION OF ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME PLACING THAT IN
CALIFORNIA STATUTE IS OF
SIGNIFICANT PRIORITY FOR US.
A REAL NOTE THAT THE STATUTE
DOES SUNSET IN.
TWENTY SO THANK YOU.
ENOUGH ABOUT SAYING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION OR YOUR HUNDRED
SUPPORT VALLEY NOW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
THE AMENDMENTS MAKE IT BETTER.
IN OTHER MEMBERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
OKAY QUESTIONS.
FOR ANYBODY ON THE PANEL HERE.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH SUCH A
GOOD BILL?
EVERYONE COOPERATED ON THIS.
ONE OKAY I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
FIRST OF ALL CAN YOU EXPLAIN THE
SUNSET DATES THAT ARE THROUGHOUT
THIS BILL THERE'S SOME
INTERESTING.
SHORT PERIODS OF TIME TWO YEARS
IS PRETTY SHORT.
WHAT WE WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF ANYTHING ELSE GOES ON
ANY OF THE LEGISLATION --
WILL BE ABLE TO EVALUATE HOW
THIS BILL WORKS --
WE'VE KIND OF ABDICATED OUR
RESPONSIBILITY OVER.
IT'S WHAT WE WERE SECURE MEMBERS
AND WE WOULD GO BACK AND
ACTUALLY.
LOOK AT HOW A LAW ACTUALLY
IMPACTED COMMUNITY A WE FELT TWO
YEARS WAS WHICH WAS MUCH MORE
THAN ENOUGH TIME.
OF TO MAKE THAT EVALUATION AND
MORE IMPORTANT IF WE HAD TO DO
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS.
IT DIDN'T FORCES US TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS AND AND IN TWO YEARS
[inaudible]
BOB ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT IS
THERE'S IS VERY VERY SERIOUS
CRIME INNOCENT AFFECTING ALLEN
TO BUSINESS COMMUNITY --
CERTIFICATE LA LIVES AND SO ARE
WE SHOULD LET LANGUAGE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE COMING BACK --
AND REALLY KIND OF FORCING US IS
THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT THIS
AGAIN SOONER THAN LATER.
I THINK YOU YOU KNOW I'M
COMMITTED TO THAT I AYE
PRESENTED BILLS VERY SIMILAR
THAT GOT.
REJECTED IN THIS PARTICULAR
COMMITTEE AND SO I MIGHT AS A
JUST A VERY VERY INTERESTING
THAT AND I'M JUST TRYING TO GET
SOME CLARIFYING.
ANSWERS BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL --
STUDY COMES OUT AFTER THE
EXPIRATION DATE.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE STUDY COMES OUT AFTER
[inaudible]
SO DID.
I AM HOPING THAT WE GET
PRELIMINARY INFORMATION ON THE
STUDY.
FROM THE STUDY --
BEFORE TO FINALIZE SO WE'VE WE
DO HAVE TO MAKE ANY ADJUSTMENTS
WE CAN'T.
SO RIGHT DOES COME OUT AFTER A
BUT WE SHOULD WE SHOULD HAVE
PRETTY GOOD INFORMATION BEFORE
THAT.
KILL MY IT WHY NOT.
ACTUALLY MY FINAL QUESTION HAS
TO BE.
WITH THE FACT THAT ON THE THIRD
OFFENSE.
WHEN SOMEBODY HAS A A THEFT?
THEY'RE OFFERED DIVERSION ON THE
THIRD.
OFFENSIVE SEEMS LIKE IT SHOULD.
THE PENALTY SHOULD ESCALATE NOT
DIMINISH.
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
SO -- AND I
THINK IT REALLY DEPENDS ON ON ON
ON THE CRIME AMIGA WITH THAT
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH BAIL FOR
EXAMPLE --
WE'RE PUTTING PRE TRIAL --
RISK ASSESSMENT AND SO THIS
GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY NOT TO JUST
SPECIFICALLY GO.
WORSE AND WORSE AND WORSE YOU
YOU GIVE PEOPLE SPECIAL PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON DRUGS.
ALCOHOL PRIME AND DETONATE GIVEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO AFTER INTO
RETAIL THEFT AND YOU'RE STEALING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A DRUG OR
ALCOHOL PROBLEM.
WE GIVE THEM MORE TIME TO GET TO
PRE SUB COMPETITORS IN PROGRAMS
THAT CAN HELP THEM WITH%
ALCOHOLISM AS YOU KNOW PROBABLY
BETTER THAN I DO --
SOMETIMES FOR TO TAKE DOESN'T
TAKE ONE OR TWO TIMES.
CONTACT UNFORTUNATELY TAKE SEVEN
TIMES.
INFO DISK ALLOWS THAT. TO BE --
PART OF THE OUR OUR PART OF THAT
BUT THE THING THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT JUST
DALY JAILING PEOPLE --
INDISCRIMINATELY GOOD WHEN WE
CAN PROVIDE HIM SOME SOME
SERVICES.
THAT'S STRATEGIES KINDA CONFUSED
WE HAVE IT SEEMS LIKE IT SHOULD
BE AT THE VERY FIRST OFFENSE
INSTEAD OF THE THIRD OF FAT JOE
BILL BE SOME.
I BELIEVE IT WILL BE SOME SOME
OF DIVERSION PROGRAM SHUT AS YOU
KNOW I PUT THIRTY SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN FOR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS. FOR USE WITH
ME CAN YOU PUT HIM DIVERSION
PROGRAMS.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
DANVILLE'S HAVE THE LA DA'S
OFFICE.
DIVERSION WHETHER OR NOT THE
LEGISLATURE OR DID.
ELECTORATE THROUGH AN INITIATIVE --
A LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
CAN ALWAYS ESTABLISH A DIVERSION
PROGRAM UNLESS IT'S STATUTORILY
PROHIBITED [inaudible]
SO.
DIVERSION IS AN OPTION.
OF IS WAY IT I UNDERSTOOD UP
THROUGH THE THIRD OFFENSE
[inaudible]
OF POLICY IT WOULD BE AT LEAST
LA COUNTY --
OUTSIDE SOMEHOW NARCOTIC OR
ALCOHOL ISSUE.
OF YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
GET AT DIVERSION ON A THIRD CASE
THAT CORKED OR THE DA.
ABOUT WHAT UP WOULD OBJECT TO IT
IF IT WAS JUST BECAUSE THE
PERSON WAS CAUGHT FOR THE THIRD
TIME --
THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME KIND
OF UNDERLYING ISSUE WHERE
DIVERSION WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
IF DURING VERSION IT EXCUSE ME
IF DIVERSION ISN'T APPROPRIATE
[inaudible]
THAT.
FELIX I DON'T SPEAK FOR LA
COUNTY.
BUT WE WOULD OBJECT.
IT'S MONTH SAY THE DIVERSION IS
AWFUL DOESN'T MANDATE THAT
DIVERSION --
BE HERE. FOR GRANTED
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
YEAH YOU.
WISHED OUR SUFFERS.
IT'S GOING TO DO THAT.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY YOUR
PATIO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
QUIRK AND SANTIAGO [inaudible]
CORMS PRESIDENT --
DID.
ANYBODY ELSE SEVENTY COMMENTS
ANYTHING THAT WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
YOU IN CLASS RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE AYE VOTE.
ON A BE TEN SIXTY FIVE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO BE
CONCURRED IN JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT BOATING THAT VIDEO.
CAVIAR I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KILEY.
PALEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I FELT GAGGLE [inaudible]
USERS OUT REGULATIONS THANK YOU.
LET FOR ME EXTRA TIME VOTED
RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
CONTENT SIXTY FIVE KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I WILL HOLD A ROLL.
FOR ANOTHER --
FOUR MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL
CLOSE FOR MR SET THE OUT
.
I MAYBE TEN SIXTY FIVE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING
STANDS ADJOURNED.
YOU CAN LOOK